It's great to welcome to the program today.
Ian Haney Lopez, who is a constitutional law
professor at the University of California,
Berkeley and also author of the book Merge
Left fuzing Race and Class Winning Elections
and Saving America.
It's so great to have you on today.
Thank you.
It's really great to join you.
So the angle I'm very interested in is that
of really thinking about how to win, because
one of the areas where I've been a bit disaffected
lately with my own movement, the progressive
movement in which, you know, I consider myself
a member, is that sometimes I think we may
miss the forest for the trees when it comes
to how to win.
And you talk very interestingly about the
right and wrong way to deal with race in politics.
And sometimes the arguments that are made
are I feel overly simplistic, like identity
politics is bad or good versus actually a
discussion of what we mean by that and how
something is important to identity as race
should be discussed.
So maybe to start lay out the panorama, as
you see it, of how some of these issues are
being discussed in politics and how you would
maybe want to see that changed.
So I think the number one thing to start with
there is the idea that race is being used
as a wedge issue to divide Americans and more
particularly to divide a Democratic constituency
that used to include the white working class
African-Americans and white liberals.
Everybody understands that race is being used
as a wedge issue, but the left today is badly
divided in how to respond.
The more centrist position, though, this is
a position that's also adopted by economic
populists like Bernie Sanders, is to focus
on winning over white voters and to understand
or to believe that talking about race will
alienate white voters.
And so to adopt as a racial strategy the tactic
of not talking about race at all.
So all of this sort of among centrist Democrats
and among some sort of radical economic populist,
there's a tendency to go colorblind, to emphasize
economic issues and to downplay the centrality
of race.
That's on one side.
On the other side, especially among racial
justice activists, you have a very strong
sense that we need to talk about race.
We need to talk about it both in terms of
the systematic violence by government against
communities of color, violence that's evident
in mass incarceration and over policing and
mass deportation, ice enforcement, but also
in the consistent neglect of communities of
color that we need to address it and we need
to address as well frontally and head on the
use of race as a as a wedge issue in politics.
That's the that's the divide.
Both camps are thinking about how to deal
with race.
And they're coming up with very different
solutions.
Ignore it and hope you can change the conversation
or attack it head on.
So there is one I'll call it a proposed solution
that I read about frequently.
And I want to see whether you think that it
really is sort of up to the challenge of dealing
with this issue in a productive way, which
is talk about race, but always make it a race
class narrative like that's that's the prescription.
That's how you do it.
You talk about class understanding that race
is part of it.
You meld them together.
You don't alienate anybody.
Does does that shake?
How do you how would you analyze that idea?
So so that's the idea that I sort of come
to a number of years ago and worked on with
unions and then ultimately put together a
research project, the race class narrative
project, using communication specialists and
pollsters.
And here's the core idea.
And I and I really want to make this point
as sharply as I can.
This is not a typical race plus class.
We should do both type move.
This is a paradigm change in how we think
about the relationship between race and class.
It's a paradigm change because what it's saying
is race and class are not in the United States
separate.
They're completely dependent on each other.
Or to put that more concretely in the class
war that the rich are winning, their number
one weapon is racial division.
The rich are siphoning more and more wealth
to themselves because they've been successful
in dividing us along race lines.
And this has very clear implications if you.
Want to if you want economic populism.
And if you want racial justice, because what
it says is if you want economic populism,
you have to fight race as a do as a tactic
for dividing American voters.
And what it says is if you want racial justice,
you have to fight racial division.
You have to make it clear to whites that they
have their own pragmatic interests in opposing
racial division so that whites will understand
that they have their own pragmatic interest
in supporting racial justice.
I'm reminded of the sort of status quo that
exists in much of the agricultural world that
deals with immigration, where we've seen large
corporations that benefit from both documented
and undocumented immigrant labor very successfully
convince a lot of Americans that this is really
about our brown people stealing your jobs.
And that seems to me to have been a very effective
way of taking the attention off of the fact
that these corporations want to pay the lowest
possible wages, even if they are not fair
wages, that these corporations disproportionately
take advantage with very little consequence
of undocumented immigrant labor because those
rules are often ignored by the government
as priorities.
Is that an example of how this is being weaponized
in a sense, as you describe?
You know, it's a really great example because
it illustrates two distinct phenomena.
We have to keep both in mind.
One way to think about the connections between
race and class is to think about the way in
which economic exploitation of people of color
has been the foundation for this country.
So you can think about it as the racialization
of Native Americans, as inferior as an excuse
to take land or the racialization of people
from Africa as black, as an excuse for slavery
and so on through Manifest Destiny and through
today's exploitation of immigrant labor and
especially undocumented immigrant labor.
This is a story that says race and class focus
on what's happening to communities of color
in the way they're economically exploited.
A very, very important story.
But here's the point.
Don't stop there.
The race and class are fuzed throughout the
American economy.
And as importantly, throughout the American
government, which regulates the economy.
And this is the other part of the story that
you surfaced.
Not only are corporations explored exploiting
brown and black and Asian people, but they're
also turning around and saying to whites the
cause of economic misery in your life or these
undeserving threatening others, blame them,
hate government, because government supposedly
cares more about them than it does about you.
You're on your own and a buy a gun and B,
trust the marketplace because through hard
work you'll take care of yourself.
And if you fail, you alone are responsible.
And what this means is that the entire economy,
the entire government, the way government
is captured by the rich is also a function
of racial narratives in our political sphere,
in our culture.
This is incredibly important.
Race and class is not just a story about what's
happening to communities of color.
It's a story about what's happening to the
United States as a whole.
It's a story about what has happened to us
over the last 50 years.
We've seen the greatest transfer of wealth
upward from all of us into the economic stratosphere
that we've seen in a century.
Why?
Because many Americans were convinced to vote
their racial fears.
You cannot understand surging economic inequality
that impoverishes almost all of us, including
whites, without focusing on the way in which
race has been used as the principal weapon
against all of us.
Yes.
So that gets to Trump in 2016.
And I would be interested in hearing your
thoughts about how in the post-mortems of
what happened, there have been all sorts of
different analysis that purport to know what
it was that allowed Donald Trump to win.
Now, one merely mathematical point is when
you're talking about about seventy thousand
votes in three states, that could have flipped
it.
We want to be careful about pointing to any
one thing, because there's probably 30 different
things that could have made a seventy thousand
vote difference.
But what I want to focus it on with you is
the fear of losing status.
That was in the minds of many voters who did
ultimately vote for Trump.
How does that tie into the race class analysis?
Trump wins overwhelmingly because of his success
in appealing to racial resentment and racial
anxiety.
But we should be clear, Trump was not the
originator of that strategy.
That's a 50 year old strategy.
Republicans have been trying that since 1964.
Right.
And especially since 1970, it has been their
principal route to building popular support
to winning elections.
So when we look at Mitt Romney's numbers of
90 percent of Mitt Romney's support came from
white voters.
Same with with Donald Trump.
Three out of five whites voted for Mitt Romney.
Same with Donald Trump.
98 percent of Republican elected officials
are white.
Similar numbers under Trump.
Donald Trump pushes more aggressively a strategy
that has been in place and has been working
for the Republicans for 50 years.
Not since 1964 has a Democratic candidate
for president won a majority of the white
vote.
This is very, very much about race.
But it's also important to pause and say that
doesn't mean this isn't about class.
There's Arnold.
Is that this debate?
Is it race or is it class?
For many people afraid of losing status, they
have lost status.
They have lost position.
Their lives are in peril.
Many whites are in trouble.
They're under tremendous stress.
This is the sort of research that talks now
about depths of despair, suicide, violence,
drug addiction, like most of us.
Many whites are under tremendous pressure.
And what's happening is that the Republicans
have created that pressure by siphoning wealth
up into the up to the very rich.
But they've also turned around and said, you
know, why in your life is in such danger?
It's because of people of color.
They're coming in.
They're flooding the country.
They're taking what they don't deserve.
And they're also violent.
And they don't respect life the way with the.
We do, right.
This is a race story to provide a frame to
interpret economic hardship.
I want to be very clear.
Economic hardship is not the main thing here.
Many people like Robert Reisz start by saying
economic hardship verte.
First, then people look for someone to blame.
That's not the history.
Dog whistling starts and is tremendously successful
at a time.
In 1970 1972, when most working class whites
were doing remarkably well.
Race has its own independent power, but race
and class combined in a vicious circle.
The more people vote, the racial fears, the
more they elect politicians who serve the
plutocrats, the more those politicians turn
around and rigged the system to help very
rich and beggar the rest of us.
The more they feel stressed and look for someone
to blame and are encouraged to use race as
the focus of their hatred and their anxiety,
it becomes a vicious circle and no one better
embodies that than Donald Trump.
The last thing I want to touch on and we have
sort of limited time left is I want to get
your thoughts on the identity politics debate
that is sort of existing on the left.
I'll give you my sort of 20 second position,
which is I am against the use of identity
as a cudgel, as a basis on which to silence
someone, as the basis on which to disqualify
somebody, etc..
But I do believe that one's identity gives
insight into what it is like to experience
the world through that identity.
And so we should want that.
We should welcome that and we should listen
to it.
That's where I kind of land on it.
I don't know if that is a coherent strategy
for electoral politics, however.
Oh, I think it is.
I would just extend it further and I would
say it's always identity politics more than
anything else.
Political scientists and Democratic realists
understand people are voting in terms of a
series of questions who am I in this society?
Who are my friends?
Who threatens me?
Who can I work with?
Those are questions of identity and we're
all thinking in those terms.
So the problem with a term like identity politics
is when it's applied to some groups, but not
to others.
We should all be thinking that all of us are
operating on organizing, voting in terms of
identity.
And what that means is we need to create this
sort of identity that includes an awful lot
of us, a super majority of us, because only
with a bigger we only with an inclusive identity
that takes.
Seriously?
Can we actually create the wave election that
we need to change the direction in this country
and this is where that race class fusion becomes
so important, because what it says is all
of us want to take care of our families.
All of us want to a world in which we're welcome
and respected and safe.
But some people are trying to divide us.
Let's come together over those lines of division.
Let's come together specifically across racial
lines.
Because when we come together and understand
we're all in this together, then and only
then can we build the political power to really
change this country's direction.
And that's going to be good for all our families,
whether we're white, black or brown.
Everybody's helped when we realize all of
our fates are linked.
Very, very interesting.
We've been speaking with Ian Haney Lopez,
who is a constitutional law professor.
The book Merge Left fuzing Race and Class
Winning Elections and Saving America.
Thank you so much for talking to me today.
I really appreciate your time.
Thanks so much.
I really appreciate the conversation.